Écoutez bien Jacques Attali
dire l'exact contraire de ce qu'il raconte
depuis 40 ans,
la question de la frontière est essentielle.
Et dans l'idéologie européenne,
depuis mille-neuf-cent-cinquante-huit,
on a tout fait pour détruire les frontières internes,
très bien, mais aussi externes.
On a commencé par la destruction des toutes les euh.
Droits de douane à l'extérieur,
et aujourd'hui, nous sommes 1 passoire.
Si on garde l'Europe d'un point de vue, euh,
le contexte est ultra bien financé,
le budget de contact n'a pas cessé d'augmenter, oui,
mais d'un point de vue c'est dit global,
l'Europe est 1 passoire,
l'Europe est 1 passoire aux investissements étrangers,
l'Europe est 1 passoire au produit étranger.
L'Europe ne sait pas se protéger,
non, elle ne veut pas se protéger.
C'est vrai, l'idéologie,
l'idéologie ultralibérale de la concurrence
qui a interdit à l'Europe
d'avoir 1 politique industrielle
qui aurait protégé nos industries
face aux concurrents extérieurs.
Et déjà 1 1ère chose à faire si on a pas 1, 1 ça,
1 protection économique.
Merci Jacques Attali,
mais on est en plein dedans depuis plusieurs années,
mais vous êtes en plein dedans,
mais vous n'avez rien fait.
Mais c'est pas vrai. Non, rien, c'est totalement faux.
Absolument rien de dire, vous,
vous datez. J'suis désolée de vous dire que vous datez,
mais vous parlez d'une Europe,
mais vous parlez d'une Europe
qui date d'il y a il y a 20 ans.
Non, madame,
je parle d'une robe qui est en train d'échouer.
Sur ce, pour le.
Coup, c'est 1 point d'accord entre entre Jacques Attali
et demi-crainière,
bien sûr, 1 robe qui est en train d'échouer sur ce point
parce que l'idéologie ultralibérale de la concurrence,
c'est terminé,
on l'a. Mais non, madame,
j'ai quelqu'un dans votre tête,
mais pas dans la réalité.
je suis pas dans ma tête,
c'est vraiment dans mon travail quotidien.
Mais vous pouvez, mais moi, je vis pas dans ma bulle, je.
Je suis en train de travailler là-dessus.
Non, c'est pas 1 preuve,
c'est pas 1 organe
domicile
sur ce point de frontière qui est 1 point majeur.
Euh, majeur pour vous.